ciao benvenuto sul nostro sito incontri
si guarda non me ne parlare come la tua
ragazza ideale ma direi capelli lunghi
ok alta ok magari non fake beh questo
non ve lo posso assicurare ok
fino adesso che risultati abbiamo un
goblin shrek prendi kruger e una
tartaruga
grossa ma se vuoi scoprire altri profili
sono 16 euro e 99 al mese ok no guardano
un interesse per avere il nostro
silenzio sul fatto che fa vincesse
iscritto al nostro sito di incontri sono
altri 25 euro al mese ma come vogliamo
fare 50 ok va bene famiglie degli altri
profili grazie per il tuo pagamento
oddio selena gomez c ome toto selena
gomez sto per suonare alla porta
buona fortuna
ciao baby